Google Cloud update did you know that if
you're a researcher interested in
exploring the benefits of cloud for your
projects you can apply to the Google
Cloud research credits program The Real
World impact of this program spans from
analyzing climate change to identifying
disinformation online learn more about
the wide range of projects and the
impact they're making on the blog or at
next 2023 with over 4 trillion photos
and videos over 1 billion users Google
photos needed a database Solution that's
highly scalable reliable and secure
spoiler alert spanner fit perfectly head
to the blog to learn more about how
Google photos scaled rapidly with
spanner Google Cloud next is just around
the corner so don't forget to register
and stay tuned for more information on
how you can make the most of your time
there check out the links below for
everything that we covered on this
week's